معنى من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري
والاستراتيجي سياده اللواء اهلا وسهلا بك
كيف تقيم الوضع العسكري اذا في ظل
الاتهامات المتبادله الغره الاسرائيليه
اولا وما قيل انه اطلق من عبر الحدود
يعني اسرائيل نفذت قبل هذا الحادث سبع
ضربات خلال فتره اسبوع على اهداف معظمها
اهداف ايرانيه وقتل اثنين من ضباط الحرس
الثوري الايراني وبالتالي اعتاد الجميع
على هذا الاجراء الاسرائيلي والان حتميه
الرد اعتقد من وجهه النظر الحكومه العالي
في اسرائيل اكبر من السابع في السابق كانت
عمليات تعقب شاحنات اسلحه تعقب ايه
امدادات او اي صواريخ الان هناك اطلاق نار
خاصه وانها توعدت
بمعاقبه الجهات المسؤوله
تقريبا كان الرد الاسرائيلي كما هو متوقع
ولم يخرج عن دائره المالوف في لبنان كان
الرد على مناطق خالي
تعطي يقين تام ان حزب الله لن يرد من جنوب
لبنان لانه لم يتم الضرر لا بقواته ولا
ببيئته العاضنه فيما يتعلق بغزه الوضع
مختلف قلنا في ذلك اليوم بان الرد على غزه
هو الاثقل لماذا لانه وسائل الدفاع في غزه
قياس المحزب الله محدوده الان في الجانب
السوري الرد سهل جدا يمكن تنفيذه سواء
بالمسيره بمنظوبات صواريخ بمظلومات مدفعيه
نقاط تواجد الفصائل الشيعيه المدعومه
ايرانيا معروفه بالارقام والاعداد
والاحداثيات خاصه فيما يتعلق بمثلث الموت
او في منطقه الجولان السوري الحالي
نعم نعم وبالتالي يعني ما الذي تتوقعه متى
الذي يمكن ان يكون في في ظل هذه الاتهامات
للسوريين وايضا النفي الذي يقوم به
المسؤولون اللبنانيون هل نتجه في تصعيد في
سوريا في جنوب لبنان في غزه كذلك ام فتره
هدوء ام ماذا
لا يعني لن يكون هناك تصعيد بمعنى التصعيد
ولا هذا رئيس التصريح رئيس الوزراء
اللبناني اختصر معظم الاشكاليات عندما نسب
الامر الى جماعات غير منظمه اي يعني يقال
في العمليات الفدائيه والجهاديه الذئاب
المنفرده وهنا تشبيه تقريبا قريبا من
مصطلح الذئاب المنفرده اي اشخاص يقومون
بهذا العمل لا غير محسوبين على تنظيمات
وبالتالي كانه رفع العبء عن كاهل حزب الله
عن حماس عن الجيش اللبناني عن الجيش
السوري وغير ذلك والان يبقى العمل مؤطر
كما قلت لك ان المليشيات المسؤوله وقد
تكون مليشيات شيعيه المسؤوله معروفه بدرجه
كبيره مواقعها واعدادها وحتى
اصلها افغانيه باكستانيه عراقيه سوريه
لبنانيه شكرا جزيلا لك الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز الدويري